[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to City
skylines 2 and welcome back to Saint
Luke first of all I want to thank
everyone for the amazing responses that
I got on my last video I really wasn't
expecting the video to do that well
first of all but also the comments were
very kind so thank you all and
um in general I'm extremely happy about
how everything's been going not just for
my video but also with this whole thing
that Paradox is doing where a bunch of
creators get the game a bit earlier and
we have waves in which we can release
videos I saw there were some questions
about this on the first video but
basically a whole group of people have
gotten an early access copy of the game
and around certain days we're allowed to
make videos up to certain milestones and
also the video is only only allowed to
be half an hour long at most so that's
why everything is releasing very much in
a coordinated way but I think it's
something that's a lot of fun for us
creators to do as well and um giving you
guys a good view into what's possible in
the game without releasing the current
build to the public because while it
doesn't really have me concerned you can
definitely tell that this is a build
that still needs a little bit of work
before it's finished for the final
release date and in some ways they even
already started incorporating some
feedback like the contour lines which
have been added since the last video and
you can actually notice that at the
start of this video the stuff that I'm
recording right now I don't have the
contour lines yet but at the end of this
time lapse you'll see by that time I'm
on a version of the game which has the
contour lines added so stuff like that
is pretty cool to see as well I think
anyway overall responses to the first
video seem to be that people were glad
that I was trying my hand at a European
city and making some rural areas and
which I kind of figured would happen uh
understandably I think a lot of creators
are American and
also to be honest it's just a little bit
easier to make rigid cities in a game
like this so I kind of figured everybody
would more or less uh gravitate toward
that direction or just show off the game
and all the different elements that were
added to it which to be honest I haven't
done there were also some people asking
why I didn't show off more what the game
is like and what functionalities the
game has and I'm just gonna be honest I
think you're better off watching
somebody else's video for that I'm just
going to continue what I've been doing
in the first video and just build some
rural areas Place loads of trees because
yes this also means that a lot of the
stuff that I'm doing here is just
placing trees it is what it is
um but you know the goal of this I think
makes it worth it that is making as
large of a somewhat realistic railroad
area as I can to really give the the
city some context then I think it needs
to live in and it's a lot of fun to do
this stuff actually for my next City
build I might even take it further and
first build a whole rural area and don't
build any City anything whatsoever and
then try to see how a city would
realistically grow into that area
because during this build I tried to
keep in mind what a city filled in on
Old rural plots would look like as they
would realistically uh or yeah
historically
grow but yeah it's it's a little bit too
much effort to First build all of the
fields so I'm just trying my hand at
doing this a little bit like a doodle if
you will which kind of makes it fun as
well as much as these time lapses look
like not that much is happening or it's
kind of all the same personally I found
it really fun to just turn on some music
and work on all of these three lines and
shape out some squiggly Wiggly Farm
Fields it's just very I don't know it's
kind of like a meditation almost it's
pretty chill so it's all fun to do as
well anyway there were some small
mistakes I think that need
um well some kind of acknowledgment the
first one and this is the biggest one is
right hand driving a bunch of people
correctly noticed that I had right hand
driving turned on on this map still you
can turn on left hand driving and I
really should have but I forgot and I
went back later to see if I could change
it
but unfortunately and understandably
it's not possible to change that
afterwards so this map should have been
left hand driving all along I don't know
how what to do about it might actually
mirror my videos in the end that might
work but then every all the text is
gonna be messed up it is what it is
um I still think it doesn't change too
much about you know the general
experimentation of how to make this area
look and whether the buildings and the
roads and the trees and everything can
fit for a realistic English build but um
it is it is a bit of a shame it's like
the smallest most stupid mistake you can
make to ruin all of the work that you
put into it otherwise so I'm just gonna
stop mentioning it and hopefully you
guys will forget about it or pretend
that this is some sort of uh alternate
universe in which the English decided to
drive on the right side of the road who
knows it is what it is uh and then
there's the case of um the bulldozer
brush which wasn't really a mistake on
my part but it definitely makes doing
all of this work a little bit harder
than I think it should have there is no
bulldoze the bulldozer brush as far as I
know
um which makes the leading trees and
especially the large forests that we
have on this map a little bit tiresome
so that's something that you notice in
some of the time lapses and it also
makes the whole tree placing thing take
a bit longer than I would like it to
so that's something that personally I
would like to see changed or otherwise
I'm pretty sure there's going to be a
mod for that eventually but you know it
is what it is
and speaking of which
my opinion is that this current build of
the game
well personally anyway doesn't really
matter all that much because this is
just the vanilla game and
um everybody knows that this game will
be heavily modded just like City
skylines one so this isn't really the
final product in that sense especially
if you're like me and you want to go for
detail and trying to make realistic
cities this is really just to see what
the foundation is like and if I compare
this Foundation to the foundation of
City skylines one it's a day and night
difference this is just so much better
then honestly I can't wait for the full
release and and to see what kind of mods
and assets people end up making and how
that's going to change the game because
if it's already this much better from
the start you know even if it's not
perfect
I think there's a lot of potential there
and that's what I'm looking forward to
mostly I think this is just a little
testing ground to see uh what the the
foundation is like but once the training
wheels are on for this game we're gonna
do some amazing stuff I think
um also a small mistake then I think is
worth pointing out uh from the last
video and I don't think it's really a
mistake but it is a fair point
some people said that Saint Luke isn't
really the most English town name ever
which is very fair I've too watched the
map men and there's a very interesting
episode about uh British Town names
which I highly recommend watching and
it's all about why their towns are well
a unpronounceable b they have different
pronunciations for the same letters all
the time and see they're just kind of
weird I don't think that was the way
that they told it in the video but
that's my general observation so really
my uh my actual project name for this
build
um was something along the lines of
squiggle diggles to sure it's
unpronounceable it's like I practiced so
many years to pronounce worcestershire
sauce
um but even that wasn't perfect but yeah
something along the lines of us squiggle
diggles to sure but um sounds a little
bit more English but it wasn't gonna cut
it for the video so I just very quickly
came up with Saint Luke I think I saw a
church somewhere scanning around Google
Maps so like a little Hamlet with a
similar name and I was like you know
that'll do but it's not the most typical
English sounding name so for some of the
hamlets that I'm building in this video
and any of the future
um The Villages and stuff in this build
I'll just be using a name generator
because it makes stuff way easier and
it's very fun to just click on a name
generator for British names and just
look at the stereotypes and roll out of
it it's amazing so many of the names are
just so typically British and kind of
ridiculous sometimes and you can just
infinitely combine them as well so it's
actually a lot of fun I I kind of wish I
actually built more villages in this
build just so I could hit the name
generator more often and try to come up
with weird combinations of the stuff
that the generator comes up with and
just have a good old time but alas there
are some other things to do like
finishing off this map
for this video my ambition was to finish
this whole island so this map we we have
a large island which is the starting
Island and um it's made out of many
tiles I don't know exactly how many kind
of depends on which tiles you buy
because you don't necessarily need to
complete the whole island of course
um which I'm not going to do either or
at least I'm gonna use the whole island
but some tiny little bits and Bops might
be in a different tile and I think it's
a waste to buy those tiles when I want
to save my tiles to make a huge
Metropolis on the other side of the
water so
um yeah my ambition was to finish this
island and it's going to be mostly rural
areas once again but we've done a lot of
those already so the ones that I'm
building here are some of the last rural
parts that we'll get to and will also be
making some some other towns besides the
Saint Luke in the middle towns won't be
quite as large as sound Luke and Saint
Luke is
um but they'll be up there I think
um and then we'll have a nice
combination of rural urban Village like
atmosphere
there were some arguments that Saint
Luke isn't quite a village it's probably
more of a town already and that's very
fair but the Milestone was called Grand
Village and I figured it would just fit
best for the title and the last little
feedback thing about the last video is I
had some comments um saying that I was
basically doing a UK build and to stop
calling the UK England and while that is
very fair I'm from the Netherlands and
understandably our country gets called
Holland instead of the Netherlands very
frequently so I kind of know how it
feels
I am definitely going for an England
inspired build there was one comment I
don't know who it was but if you're
listening uh shout out
um leave a comment and I'll continue
down below for being a legend who
um responded that this looked like it
was inspired by the area of Plymouth and
that's exactly right that's more or less
where I was looking on Google Maps just
kind of scrolling around looking at
different fields and Villages and seeing
what it all looked like and trying to
emulate it a little bit none of the
roads are exactly emulated from it but
the idea behind the three lines the
squiggly roads and the way how to fill
in the fields between them is very much
based on that area so I would consider
this an attempt at a southern English
build
um if not for the fact that of course
the architecture is slightly off and we
don't have the hedges and everything you
know it's not 100 perfect it's not a
like I would say it looks completely
like a South England Wood but honestly
for a vanilla game I'm already very
happy I think in City skylines one it
would be impossible to do anything
remotely English in a beta or in a
vanilla uh game so I'll take it honestly
I think it's pretty good now here I
started work on the second town on the
island which is uh definitely a little
bit larger than a village I guess and
starting off
I figured I would need to add a little
Ring Road that looks like it was added
long after this Village
um it started existing with some
roundabouts in it because ring roads
with roundabout are a very common sight
among some smaller towns in England just
roundabouts in general it's very fun
also looking at the highways and seeing
how many Highway entrances and exits are
full of roundabouts dog bone
interchanges and stuff like that or a
giant roundabouts with entrances and
exits on all sides to to highways seeing
stuff like that is a very common at
least from my Google Maps research and
my own experience of visiting the UK so
always good to have lots of roundabouts
plus I am personally a big fan of
roundabouts so you know what it is and
in the middle of that we have like the
older Street Network I was thinking of
this town as having grown alongside the
beach here so it's kind of following the
beach in its Street pattern but then
also has doing some squiggly roads and
the roads are a little bit packed
together in the center and there's two
roads alongside the water are probably
the real City Center with the High
Street
um with all of the shops and stuff and
some dense row houses and the rest of
the town is going to be a little bit
less dense
and then just outside the Ring Road we
have some newer commercial developments
you know from uh the past few decades
that didn't quite fit into the town
anymore and that's a little bit removed
from it and also some other developments
that maybe sprung up in some older Farm
Fields uh like the one over here the
little Panhandle that kind of goes off
of the Ring Road
um that's not gonna be a Ring Road So
Much Anymore
um so that's my uh idea behind this town
I think the layout actually feels pretty
realistic pretty nice I'm uh happier
with it than the first town than Saint
Luke for sure but that's usually what
happens you know you start practicing a
little bit more and then things go A bit
more well I suppose
um but still I'm happy with the both of
them but I think this one overall
manages to capture the feel and look to
me of a town like this just a little bit
more it also reminds me somewhat of of
Dutch towns I think the difference is
that while many Dutch towns do have very
similar ring roads and roundabouts and
Commercial developments and stuff like
that it's a bit more planned it's a bit
more straight
and way more row houses that are
arranged in a very typical Dutch setting
not to mention that for Dutch towns you
can very very clearly often tell which
decade they were at certain
neighborhoods they were designed in and
the differences are a little bit less
significant I think for English towns
but then again I'm biased on this so
might not be able to tell exactly this
isn't exactly my forte to begin with in
terms of a theme it's just what I think
is the the best doable European theme
with this map and with the stuff that we
have in the game so far
anyway going on to the other side of the
island there's some other work to be
done as you can see on my demand bar I
need to build Industrial and Commercial
which I think is a little bit annoying
because I really wasn't planning to have
that much industry on the island and I
mostly wanted to build little towns but
it is what it is we need to build to the
demand so it's time to add a big Port
over here
um so that's what we're building and I'm
trying to make it look like it's
actually some kind of cargo Harbor which
it really isn't but at least with the um
the the what what is it actually well
the passenger service that we have built
it kind of looks like it could maybe be
some kind of cargo Harbor or if at the
very least at first glance uh from above
it looks like that's the sort of thing
that's going on here
um so from a realism perspective and
from an aerial cinematic Viewpoint
perspective I think I'm pretty happy
with it
something I didn't notice while I was
building all of this is that the chicken
farm in the bottom left here looks a
little bit wonky with all of those
different stables for the chickens
um you don't call them stables for
chickens I have no idea what to call
them for chickens doesn't matter
um that's kind of what it is but uh
that's what you get when you have an
animal field I suppose it's a bit
different for the vegetable farming
anyway here we have the final larger
town of the island which I figured it
would make sense to have the towns on
the edges of the island and especially
this town here it's kind of on the
entrance of the sea route so I think
realistically historically uh this would
be where a town would be located it's
also on a hill so it's got a great view
um so unfortunately I don't have access
to a lighthouse but I think
realistically this is exactly the kind
of spot where you would want a
lighthouse to be as well
um but yeah
because we don't have it we just got a
little town here with a little bit of
commercial development uh and some row
houses but it's definitely the smallest
of the town so far also I am naming the
port area after this town because even
though uh it's a little bit removed from
it I think it's still closer to it than
the center of Saint Luke and I think the
port started existing a while ago long
before it grew into the giant industrial
area that it is nowadays so it's
probably a little bit more connected to
this town than it is to Saint Luke
um but that's just a little bit of lore
that I came up with along the way
something which I also do a lot is
placing trees as close to the houses as
possible or around the backyards and
stuff like that because realistically
people will place trees in their
backyards and stuff but what I noticed
is that the houses do spawn with some
bushes and trees but they don't actually
grow the way that Standalone trees do so
to give the town the look of a town with
real trees in it and to make them
actually more Lush I decided to plant
trees everywhere so the same goes for
the town here and then there we go using
some districts tool and shenanigans to
actually give everything names and
um coming up with strange names on the
generator was a fun exercise to do as
well
so yeah now we really see the map
developing a little bit I was quickly
figuring out if I could do maybe any
energy generation or whatever but um
it's not really a good spot for uh to
wind turbines anywhere on the island so
I'm just gonna continue importing my
electricity
which I am super glad in this game that
we can import electricity and all kinds
of services and Export them as well
because it means that starting out in
your game isn't as dependent on certain
sources
um of energy or other services like it
was in city scan is one which I think
makes a lot of sense most cities aren't
completely self-sufficient you'll always
rely on neighboring cities and the
country that the city is in at large for
the electricity Network and other larger
infrastructure like that so to have to
build it all on your own as a city
itself just doesn't really make much
sense it's not as realistic but also
from a gameplay perspective it means
that the start of your game is always
trying to do all kinds of infrastructure
stuff that you really don't want to be
concerned with so I think starting off a
city in the city in this game is a
little bit easier and more fun than in
City skylines one even from a gameplay
perspective but it's a bit more
realistic as well and overall it means
that even though there were some realism
elements added to the game like the way
that electricity works and water and
sewage pipes work now they also managed
to make it a bit more fun from a
gameplay perspective I think the same
goes for the sewage system
we don't have to lay pipes underground
anymore it's all just part of the road
Network the same goes for electricity
and it's just more realistic for one
because that is the way it is in real
life it's all just underneath roads and
basically every road has the basic
Services the somewhere underneath it
but also it's just much more fun from a
gameplay perspective because it makes
life easier when it comes to stuff like
that and it means you have more time to
focus on the fun stuff like laying out
your road Network and placing trees and
houses and seeing the city grow around
it so yeah good stuff all around I think
pretty happy with the changes they made
when it comes to that now one last thing
that I think is a worthy critique of
this build is terraforming I got some
comments about the terraforming then
it's a little bit of a flat map which is
very fair
um and it means it's not super realistic
in terms of the uh the British
Countryside that it's pretending to be
a lot of the uh English rural
Countryside that I'm speaking of
is very as quickly because of the
Rolling Hills that it's uh built in and
a lot of the way that towns and Villages
are placed and have grown over time is
also dependent on that same geography
and we can't really play with that as
much in this map because it's a bit more
flat even though it does have some nice
Rolling Hills I think uh the way that
all of these paths are squiggly and
everything is a little bit exaggerated
because the map is kind of flat which is
very fair but also it is what it is I
don't really have enough space to
realistically start terraforming
everything to make it a bit more hilly
it would also take a lot of time and
um yeah not having the entire map
unlocked means that you're gonna have
some weird edges around that as well so
in the end I opted not to do this and
just work with what we have here and to
be very honest my future plans are to
make a Dutch series if it turns out that
we have enough mods and assets to do
stuff like that I would love to do a
Dutch Series in the full release if
possible so
yeah honestly I'm not even too concerned
with learning how the terraforming Works
um I'm just not gonna build too many
cities on the Hills I think eventually I
already feel like I'm kind of doing
something uh out of my depth here by uh
trying my hand at a an English build but
it is also fun to learn some new stuff
and and try and mess around with it so
uh yeah fair enough
and with that we've arrived at the last
part of this video and the last few
squiggly lines and other finishing
touches that I wanted to do to really
finish this island and I have some small
tips I guess to share as well or
insights in how I'm doing all of this
stuff so for this quickly roads and the
the three lines and bushy lines and
stuff like that
um usually for these I decide to just
turn off snapping and that's an easy way
to make these things as quickly as
possible and then just whack around with
the cursor and see wherever the curves
take you just kind of randomly it really
is like doodling
sometimes you have the terrain to follow
realistically you really want to do that
but for videos like these my land is
just a little bit too flat so while I do
follow some hills here and there and it
definitely helps to make it look more
realistic very often I also just kind of
go at it it also helps to create some
main roads first that look like they're
connecting different towns so for
instance in this case we really have
some main roads then almost in a
straight line connect some of the main
towns and Villages and then around that
you know you start getting some smaller
squiggly roads and then you start
filling in the gaps between that so it
really helps to make some main ones and
then try to see how you can fill it in
kind of randomly between it but turning
off snapping makes things a lot easier
as well and for the towns I decided to
finish this town by filling in some of
the areas that I removed near the end of
the last video I had to remove some of
these areas because they looked a little
bit a little bit wonky after I um
well uh deleted many of the houses in
them to prevent my XP from going up so
that I can have enough space or time for
the trees to grow but ever since they've
been empty and now it's time to fill
them in again and actually I'm a little
bit happier with how I filled them in as
opposed to how they were originally
because now they really started looking
like some fields that were incorporated
into the town and they built some roads
into to create some suburbs so I think
all things considered it actually kind
of helped the the overall build over
here I had to build a small expansion to
the industrial area because I still had
a lot of demand for industry and
Commercial zones
um
it is what it is there's no way to get
around it I just had to build a little
bit so I decided to expand into the
forest and make it seem like it was some
sort of very new expansion and also this
gives me a nice space to uh build the
road maintenance building because I
still hadn't built it and though my
roads do kind of look fine they are
absolutely terrible and disgusting and
one look at the info panel about Road
quality told me that it's worse than
Belgium so that's what it is and also I
decided to fill in some of these areas
with industry and Commercial as well so
now this uh industrial area has finally
grown to attach itself to Saint Luke
itself but I think that's also a
realistic process of acidic growing over
time so I'm actually pretty happy with
it even though it wasn't my original
plan sometimes trying to build an
organic city is kind of approaching it
like Bob Ross there are no mistakes just
happy little accidents anything that
happens that's unplanned actually makes
your city look more unplanned and
organic so that's kind of what you're
looking for anyway that's it for the
time lapse so I'm Gonna Leave You guys
with some more cinematic shots I hope
you enjoyed this episode and
um looking forward to see you on the
next one bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]